Welcome to the video on
the Taylor Theorem and
Taylor polynomials.
And we've actually
already touched on this.
When we did the videos on
approximating functions with
polynomials, we used Maclaurin
series, which is actually a
special case of the Taylor
polynomial or the
Taylor Theorem.
And we just pick, we
approximate the function
around x equals 0 when we
did the Maclaurin series.
But in general, you could
approximate a function
around any value.
And if you do it around
something other than 0, it's
kind of the more general
case, and we're dealing
with the Taylor polynomial.
So what is that?
Let me just write the
definition down, and then we'll
do a couple of examples, and
then we'll graph it to
get the intuition.
So a Taylor polynomial says
that if I have a differentiable
function f of x, and I want
to approximate it with a
polynomial at c, so at some
value of x equals c, I want to
approximate this function.
So let me just draw a quick and
dirty one, and we'll actually
draw an accurate one later.
So let's say that that's
my axes, this is my
function f of x.
So I could pick some value
c, some value x is equal to
c, maybe it's right there.
So that's c.
And I would want to approximate
it, I would want to create a
polynomial that can approximate
the function around this point.
And the Taylor Theorem tells us
that the Taylor polynomial to
approximate this is, and then
I'll give you the intuition
for it in a second.
p of x.
And this looks really
complicated, but when you
do some examples, you'll
see it's not so bad.
p of x is equal to f of c plus
f prime of c times x minus c
plus f prime prime of c over,
they say 2 factorial, which is
just 2, but OK, I'll
write 2 factorial.
They do that so that you see
the pattern that emerges.
This is over 1 factorial,
really, and this is over
0 factorial, really.
Times x minus c squared plus,
I'm already running out of
space, f the third derivative,
I think at this point people
just write a 3 in parentheses,
of the function evaluated at c
over 3 factorial times x minus
c to the third, and you could
just keep adding terms.
You could go on like
this for infinity.
But let me give you the
intuition of what this is.
Let me just show you, just
to hit the point home.
Then you could plus the fourth
derivative of the function
evaluated at c times over 4
factorial times x minus
c to the fourth.
Now what's the intuition?
So first of all, what happens
to this polynomial at c?
So what's p of c?
p of c is equal to-- if p of c,
everywhere where you see an x
here, you have to
put a c, right?
So this term would be c minus
c, so that would go to
zero, or it would be 0.
This term would be c
minus c, it would be 0.
This term would be c minus
c, so it would be 0.
This term would
be c minus c, 0.
And all you'd be left
with is this f of c.
So great.
We already know that, at least
at the value of c, the
polynomial is equal
to the function.
So it's going to
intersect this line.
Right?
And actually, if we just had a
Taylor polynomial with just
that first term, what
would it look like?
Well, it would just be a
horizontal line right there.
So it would be a pretty
bad approximation.
But, what does this
second term do us?
Because we know that if
we just evaluated c.
All these other terms
just drop out.
So what do they do for us?
Well, the second term actually
ensures that the derivative of
this polynomial, evaluated at
c, is equal to the derivative
of this function,
evaluated at c.
What do I mean there?
Well, what's p prime of x?
p prime of x is equal to, well,
this is just a constant term.
It might look like a function,
but it's a function evaluated
at c, so it's just
a constant term.
And so, that's 0.
And then, what is this?
What's the derivative of this?
Well, we could use, this is
a constant term, and the
derivative of this is just 1.
So you could almost just view
this as f prime of c times x,
minus f prime of c times c
which is a constant, whatever.
So the derivative of this
expression is f of c, and then
plus the derivative of this
expression, and that's
equal to what?
2 times 2 divided by 2
factorial, which is just 1.
So it's f prime prime of
c, times x minus c, and
then plus, let's see.
3 over 3 factorial, so that's
3 over 6, we'll just have
a 2 in the denominator.
f prime prime prime of
c over, what was it, 2
times x minus c squared--
And you don't have to
worry about all of this.
And then, we could
just keep going.
But I wanted just to
show you one thing.
What is t prime at c?
t prime at c.
What is the derivative
of this polynomial when
you evaluate it at c?
Well, when you put c into this
derivative function, all these
other terms are going to drop
off, and you're just
left with this one.
Right?
Because this x minus c--
sorry, just had some walnuts.
I should have some
water with it.
If you put the c
here, they drop out.
So the derivative of this
function evaluated at c,
is equal to f prime of c.
So as you can see, what's neat
about this Taylor polynomial
is, it's equal to the function
at c, its derivative is equal
to the function at c, the
second derivative is equal
to the function at c.
And every term you add to the
Taylor polynomial actually
makes it so that that term,
derivative, of the polynomial
evaluated at c, is
equal to the function.
Hope I didn't confuse you.
The big picture is, the whole
thinking behind, I guess, what
Taylor thought of, was, wow.
If this function is infinitely
differentiable, meaning that I
can take the first, second,
third, fourth, you know, all
the way to infinity derivative
of this function, I could
construct a polynomial like
this, and i can just keep going
by adding more and more terms,
so that this polynomial's, you
know, zeroth derivative, which
is means the function, the 0,
first, second, third, fourth,
all of this polynomial's
derivatives are going to
be equal to the function.
At least around that point.
And actually, we'll see that
there's actually a whole class
of functions, that the Taylor
polynomial, if you were to take
the infinite series, is
actually equal to that
function at all points.
But anyway.
And actually, I talk a little
bit about that when I prove
that e to the i pi is equal to
negative 1, which to me was the
most amazing result
in mathematics.
Whatever, whatever.
This might have been a little
confusing for you, so let's
do a particular example.
The particulars are
always the more fun.
I think when you see me do
an example, you'll see
that it's not so bad.
I'm even going to erase
this fourth term.
So let's approximate, I
don't know, cosine of x.
So let's say that f of x
is equal to, let me do
it in a different color.
We want to approximate f of x
is equal to cosine of access.
And let's pick some
arbitrary number.
Let's not pick some number
that works well with
trigonometric functions.
Let's pick around, let's
say c is equal to 2.
No, 1.
So we're going to approximate
cosine of x around 1.
So what is the Taylor
approximation, or the
Taylor polynomial?
Well, we could just
chug through this one.
p of x, I'll do it in yellow.
p of x is equal to f of c.
So the function evaluated at c
is just cosine of 1, right?
plus s prime of c.
Well, what is the
derivative of cosine of x?
It's minus sine of x, right?
Minus sine of x, and we
want to evaluate it at c.
So it's minus sine of 1,
right? c is one, that's
we're approximating around.
Times x minus c.
And then, plus the
second derivative of x.
So what's the
second derivative?
What's going to be the
derivative of minus sine,
which is minus cosine of x?
So it's minus cosine.
But we're evaluating it at c,
so there's actually going
to be a number, right?
So c is 1.
Cosine of 1.
Over 2, right?
2 factorial is just 2.
Times x minus 1 squared,
oh, sorry, this should
be a one, right?
I said, c is equal to 1.
Times x minus 1 squared.
Let's keep going.
Plus the third derivative,
plus, what's the third
derivative of cosine?
Well, it's the derivative
of minus cosine, so
that's plus sign.
So plus sine evaluated at 1.
Sine of 1.
Divided by 3 factorial,
so that's 6 over 6 times
x minus 3 to third.
Sorry, my brain is really,
I ate too many walnuts.
Undo, edit, undo. x minus
1 to the third, right?
And then, let's do one
more term, just for fun.
So then we're going to take the
fourth derivative, which is the
derivative of the third
derivative, so the third
derivative was positive sine,
so now we're going
to be plus cosine.
Plus cosine evaluated at
1 over 4 factorial--
what's 4 factorial?
It's 3 factorial times 4.
So over 24.
Times x minus 1 to the fourth.
And we could just keep going.
The fifth derivative over 5
evaluated at 1, over 5
factorial times x minus 1 to
the fifth, and just keep
adding, but then it will
take us forever, et
cetera, et cetera.
So, what does this
thing look like?
And what I'm going to do, is
I'm going to show you how
this polynomial develops
as we add terms.
So let's see.
I have this graphing calculator
that I-- so this thing I
got from, just to give them
credit, it's my.hrw.com.
And this is the graph
of cosine of x.
So just the first term here.
Cosine of 1.
If we were to just to graph the
first term of this polynomial,
what does it look like?
So I'll just type in cosine
of 1, and graph it.
So there you go.
Just the first term
of the polynomial.
If all of these terms weren't
here, the polynomial would
just be a constant, right?
Cosine of one.
And it's a pretty bad
approximation, but at least
it equals the function
at this point.
So it gives a something.
But let's add some terms.
Let's add the
second term to it.
So what was the second term?
It was sine of 1 minus sine
of 1 times x minus 1.
Let me add that.
Graph it.
There you go.
So this is neat.
So when you just added 2
terms, what did we say?
The polynomial will be equal to
the function at x equals 1.
And now the slope is also
equal to the function.
The slope of the polynomial is
also equal to the slope of the
function at x is equal to 1.
So this is a better
approximation.
At least if we stay pretty
close to our chosen c, it's
a decent approximation
for the function.
Obviously, if we get far away,
out here, this is a horrible
approximation for the function.
But let's keep adding terms.
As you can see, I just want
to show you that I'm just
typing in the actual terms.
So let me type in
the next term.
just so you believe
that I'm doing it.
So the next term,
we'll have to see it.
Let me type it in.
So the next term is minus
cosine of 1 divided by 2
times x minus 1 squared.
And let me graph it.
OK.
So now, just to show you, I
just typed in the second
term, and now let's
look at the graph.
Now this is neat, right?
So the first term got us a
horizontal line that just
intersected the point at cosine
of 1, and it was a really
bad approximation.
Then the second term made sure
that at least the first
derivative was the same.
And so then we, the line was
just essentially the tangent
line, we only had 2 terms.
Now the third term makes sure
that the second derivative of
our polynomial at x equals 1 is
equal to the second derivative
of the polynomial
of the function.
And notice that this
green graph is concave
downwards, right?
Which means that, and so
is the function at 1.
So this is this is pretty neat.
We're getting a little bit, so
it's kind of approximating
the curve here.
It's getting a
little bit better.
Remember when we went
out far to the left?
Starting to approximate the
function better around here.
It's closer, at least.
Right?
The last time, the line just
went up, and here it was a
really bad approximation.
But let's add another term.
Let's add our third term.
Our third term, I can see
it, it's right there.
So plus sine of 1 divided
by 6 times x minus 1
to the third power.
Just to show you, I just
typed it in, right there.
Let me graph it.
That is neat.
Just with three terms on our
polynomial, well, actually,
that's the fourth
term, officially.
But the first term was
essentially-- well,
you get the point.
But we're already starting
to approximate this
pretty well, right?
Now the third derivative of the
polynomial is equal to the
third derivative of the
function at the point x is
equal to 1, and we haven't even
studied third derivatives.
That's kind of like the
concativity of the
derivative, or whatever.
But as we can see,
it approximates the
function even better.
Obviously, though, when we
go further away, it starts
to break down again.
But pretty close.
If all you saw is from
here to here, it would be
hard to tell them apart.
Let's add that last
term we calculated.
And this should be pretty neat.
Let's see.
The last term.
Plus cosine sign of
1 divided by 24.
And notice, every term, the
scaling factor, right?
Here's 1, then 1/2, then
1/6, 1/24-- it becomes
a smaller impact on it.
And it only starts to matter as
you move really, really far
away from your chosen c.
In this case 1, right.
The further out you go,
when you're close to your
point that you've picked.
these other terms don't
matter much, right?
Because you're doing 1/24,
and then 1 over 5 factorial,
et cetera et cetera.
But as you get further and
further away, these terms
become more significant, right?
As x gets further and further
away from 1, and then that's
where these start to play in,
and you see that in
the approximation.
Anyway, let me graph it.
So cosine of 1 divided by 24
times x minus 1 to the fourth.
Let me graph it.
Even neater!
And if you have some spare
time, you might just want to
keep adding terms to this.
So that's all the
Taylor polynomial is.
And I realize, this is
probably one of longest
videos I've done.
I'm pushing 17 minutes.
It's a little confusing at
first, because it gives you
this huge formula, and they
give you the c, and you're
like, what is that c, and how
do I take the derivative?
But when you actually try to
chug through it, you just
have to realize, oh.
All this is, is saying, we are
constructing a polynomial that,
at some point c that we've
picked, this polynomial's
zeroth, first, second, third,
fourth, fifth, and so on-th
derivative is going to be
equal to our function.
And actually, if we did 10
terms, or if we did all of the
derivatives, these would start
to actually equal each other.
So hopefully that
didn't confuse you.
I know when you see the formula
at first, it can be kind of
daunting, and especially,
sometimes it's even more
daunting when someone
even explains it to you.
But hopefully that gave
you some intuition.
If it didn't,
ignore this video.
See you soon.